presenting Kigali today as the
legitimate president of Venezuela as the
legitimate commander-in-chief of the
Armed Forces I am calling on soldiers
and the military to join us keeping
within the framework of the Constitution
as we always have the moment is now it
is not just a moment for peace and
decency
it is also a moment for bravery so that
peace can be restored
in Venezuela god bless you we will
achieve freedom and democracy for
Venezuela our Latin America
correspondent xavier adidas is
monitoring the situation for us from
Bogota in Colombia hi Javier what have
you been hearing and seeing in reports
there this is a story that is moving
very quickly
it is moving very quickly and as it is
normally the case in these types of
situations is very hard to tell what is
true and what is not true so far what we
have seen for sure is of course that
liberation of opposition leader Leopoldo
Lopez and several movements that seem to
be had a turning rather violent with
tear gas launches by the police but so
far we haven't seen any type of what we
would expect to be a military action
so the situation seems to be calm and
that is what the government has been
very quick to say that the situation in
the country is normal and under control
but videos from many users that are of
course hard to tell their true or not
seem to be showing a rather escalation
of the violence we've seen a lot of
people gathered on the streets in
Caracas have yet who is supporting why
though right now he says that he has the
support of what he calls a brave
soldiers who was out on the streets well
out of the street on the streets are the
supporters of gueto that we have seen
for many many months now the question is
and will continue to be if that it is
support is enough in order to actually
force a change of government in the
country that can only happen if the
population of the country really
supports wydo and there is or have been
at least so far a separation of classes
if you will the more popular classes
tend to still continue to be on the side
of Nicolas Maduro but that has been
changing quickly now as for the military
forces what we have seen so far are
members of
the air force in Venezuela that is known
to be the more disciplined part of the
military and the part that is least the
least corrupt and therefore has been
citing why do the in the strongest way
possible however of course we know that
is only a part of the military and the
girls Melo has shown us many times
already
that he is in control of the majority of
the military forces we'll see if that
changes today xavier we've just been
looking at some pictures from a little
bit earlier where one why though was on
the streets there in caracas joined by
some of his supporters as you said
remind us again what the Maduro
government has been saying how it's been
reacting to the situation well the
Maduro government is treating this as an
insurgent movement in some members of
the government even though Nikhil as a
little himself has not really referred
to this but they have said that this is
a coup or at least a trial to to force a
change of government through military
action and that is the discourse that we
have been seen so far so the government
in this is in a state of alert and in a
state of suppressing these movements in
order to maintain the order they have
been very quick to say again that the
situation in the country is under their
control but you know it is very early in
the morning still and a lot can happen
throughout the day have yet in that
Twitter message from the self-proclaimed
president one way though he called this
the final phase of his plan to oust
Nicolas Maduro that is a very striking
phrase what does that mean it is a very
tough one to answer to me because we
know that one way though has said
repeatedly that his movement is a
Pacific movement that would discard any
possibility of a military intervention
and then we see him backed by military
forces so it is a dual discourse there
that is very difficult to really
decipher what what exactly does he mean
by that
in the most romantic idea if you will
would see a very very big movement of
the population going to the presidency
and asking equalise Malouda to resign
that would be the more peaceful
alternative but from what we've seen and
from the preparations that we've seen in
the last couple of weeks and months
there always have
in important components of the military
forces there that military officers that
have come here to Colombia even
preparing for a scenario that might
include a military intervention and more
worryingly neither Colombia the
neighboring country nor the United
States have discarded the possibility of
a military intervention and we do not
know what negotiations have been
happening behind the scenes for today as
the developments are coming up I mean
yeah indeed have here that is a true it
definitely the case that we don't know
exactly what's been happening behind the
scenes I want to ask you about Leopoldo
Lopez this activist who we mentioned
also a key opposition leader he says he
was freed by the military and we saw him
on the streets a little bit earlier
these are pictures were looking at now
how significant is that it is very
significant from a symbolic point of
view no polar opposites the symbol of
the oppression against the opposition in
Venezuela he himself had initiated a
movement that had a lot of popular
support in order that obstacle has
mellowed or to force a change of
government in the country however let's
not forget that we have seen scenarios
like the one we're seeing today many
times before in Venezuela opposition
leaders have come and gone without real
change in the government without changes
in the policy or because I'm a little
and nothing can guarantee that this time
it will be different the Paulding office
is the face of a leader who was jailed
after trying to achieve what who and
what it all is trying to do today Javier
what can you tell us about the timing of
this why are we seeing one guy go launch
what he's calling this the final phase
of his plan now I mean he had originally
planned to lead a big protest tomorrow
yes many are wondering why this is
happening today and the only reasonable
explanation so far is the element of
surprise he wanted to surprise the
government that was certainly preparing
for mass mobilizations on May 1st that
is a traditional date as we all know in
many parts of the world and that was
supposed to be the day where the change
of karma in the u.s. era would come to
place by the government of one Widow
however we are seeing him act today and
this can only be to anticipate the
movements of the government and to be
quicker than he could have been a little
and his team all right our correspondent
Javier gave us monitoring the situation
for us thank you very much